The Joe Rogan Experience did you see the
guy the samurai guy on um what is it
Stanley's superhumans you saw the show
right where they they shoot the pellet
gun at them and he with the samurai
sword he cuts it in half wow yeah yeah
yeah you see that in slow motion so the
guys I think it's 500 feet a second the
gun shoots and he's just standing with
his sword and as soon as the guy shoots
you see him cutting it and he freaking
hits the pellet you look it up okay
we'll find that yeah yeah oh look at
this there we go
that's insane how crazy is this that is
insane
by the time they move the sword into
position the pellet would have traveled
past them
wow and then he finds the pellet sliced
in half
dude
you know there's people like that out
there
this is this over and over and over and
over again there's this guy who comes to
pick somebody up for an interview
and he's on a tandem and he's blind
what and he picks the the interviewer up
to Stanley Superior oh yeah echolocation
yeah and it's and they bring him to a
different city so he doesn't know
anything they put him like in the front
of a phone booth and I'm not talking to
phone booth I just open up and you see
the phone he goes That's a phone I go
okay there's a [__] that's a trash can
that's a smaller car
wow yeah just by making sounds
dude so people out there man I love that
kind of stuff
putting plates to your head did you see
that ceramic anything doesn't matter
doesn't need to be metal wood with his
mind he can rap grab anything and attach
it to his head what yeah it's also
understand this how I he said his mind
will trap it and then he does with
ceramic plates it stays it sticks to his
freaking forehead it's not a trick it's
not a trick not this the scientists are
literally going after him
but that's the same with the Joel Joel
Joel what's his name Greenstein did you
ever hear about him oh dude the the
mighty Adam no you never heard about the
mighty Adam no
Hallelujah man this guy 130 pounds
strongest man in the world
people go yeah right six of 12 pennies
he'll bite in half bite straight through
you go nah that's not two no no no he
has dentists and uh and doctors
they they were writing they're writing
uh journals about this guy because it's
impossible what he's doing you give him
a horseshoe and he says what size what a
form you want to have at the question
mark he goes like he says he becomes one
with it he can he says I just become one
with the medal he's just Benson in front
of your face
Joel uh Greenstein the Mighty the mighty
Adam
so what is this from he stopped it
playing 1928 yeah around yeah
he's fighting this isn't the time when
the Nazis came and the propaganda and
this was in New York and there's this
article about him a newspaper article
that the police says we came there to
save the crowd from him not to save him
from the crowd because he was staring
those Nazis a new
a new one wow good started wrestling
left Poland for the United States yeah
I'm gonna try to find it it's just a
bunch of articles about him but he bit
through Nails broke chains and held down
an airplane with his hair yeah so about
a guy tried it he freaking died
his assaulted by six men sent them all
the hospital Samuel handily beat up 20
Nazi sympathizers wow
dude they shot him in his forehead like
a 22 because the guy was in love with
his wife and he wanted his wife didn't
penetrate the skull
Jesus Christ yeah so here's something
this is at the very
um
I have audio
stop
I think the layers to the lumber
let's examine it
well he used his hand to put the nail in
wood
whoa
what's this
these bending nails with his teeth look
what the [__]
[Applause]
dude I read his book the same as I said
clean living no smoking no alcohol no
squandering your life Nights by playing
cards in stuffy rooms and keep oxygen
out of your lungs and inhale monoxide
and dioxide and get cancer of the lungs
and also weak heart and heart attack and
kaput
whoa weird
his book it's it's Insanity you go like
there's no way this is possible and they
go to a dentist and he checks out his
teeth and while he's doing it he bites
the metal thing that he's in his mouth
bites it in half
the guy writes about that
what are you going to do against a guy
like this